[Music]
everybody's familiar with stephen
hawking yes steven hawkins yes yes we
are
yes and how did he communicate in his
later part like a robot through one of
the t-pains used a peter but we're we're
also convinced that maybe he got taken
over by ai did he blow into it no he had
a speaking spell yeah that's what it was
remember that red thing the speak eye my
name which was actually something that
was connected to one of his working and
active cheek muscles that were able to
uh
choose different characters and put it
together and you only had like two
fingers that you could use right
dude so productive by the way we're not
nearly that productive yeah none of us
[ __ ] none of us
did he like make that this really isn't
about him i just brought him up and he
has a reference oh okay so because a
paralyzed man
communicates his first words in months
using a brain implant similar
gangster and one of the first things he
says is quote i want a beer yeah that
would be my first trip wow my kind of
guy this is a locked in als patient okay
completely paralyzed man who was left
unable to communicate for months after
losing the ability to even move his eyes
jeez
[ __ ] als dude is it worth it to spend
the extra time to just clarify that you
don't want a natty ice
or do you just say [ __ ] it i want i just
don't i would i would just be down for
anything because because when you've
been that long without a beer bro
everything's gonna [ __ ] just go okay
here let me give you a little bit of ta
on it let me give you a little technical
analysis and then from there everybody
can make their judgment on what you
would say first after a few months okay
composing sentences at a rate of just
one character per minute
so i want a beer i w-a-n-t-a-b
that would at least take 10 minutes if
you add spaces 12. one character a
minute yeah wow did they have to teach
them how to do it
or they just like i would assume if it's
a brain injury
wait it's one character a minute so wait
so can this cat like actually pick up a
bear and drink it or is is it like
coming through an iv or some [ __ ] uh i
honestly don't know i would assume it's
coming through and i've done it over
here
no it's not gonna be a beard well dude
so one of the i've talked about this
before i think but one of the most
perplexing things in my life was
christopher reeve like in a vegetative
state
relatively like he's like incapacitated
and then his wife is sitting next to him
and they're doing like an interview with
barbara walters or some [ __ ] and then he
and then um bart walsh was like does
everything work and then his wife is
like oh yeah everything works so i'm
like
okay but how's that work like yeah did
you go into detail does your dick get
hard like can you see you missed it we
were just here just here two weeks ago
with ryan's friend tj who he had shared
the story about with the uh the whole
car accident that left him paralyzed
with only a 13 chance of like coming
back
with physical movement stuff but he he
ended up recovering mostly however when
he was sitting in the hot seat two weeks
ago
nick made me ask i don't have a dirty
mind like that so nick was nudging him
like please ask him anthony lee please
come on he's like i had to ask him about
his penis function but the thing is in
his paralyzation he described it as the
first things that you begin feeling when
things coming back or first numbness
and then right it was numbness right
first numbness as if it was like a
sensation like it exists however you
almost like a phantom feeling i believe
and then pain
or or temperature was it temperature and
pain temperature and pain and then from
there because he like without his
thought or control it was kind of it
involuntarily just gets he's a legend
bro he got jacked off in the hospital
bro no but who yeah
a good friend his friend a good friend
took care of him a home girl that
stopped by a chick i hope yeah she was
like so he's not gay after that right
he wasn't the hand jobber
even if it was gay with a guy it's like
involuntary because you can't feel it so
it's like not gay it's like kind of like
the you know i i really didn't ask that
what i wanted to know was the cold
question in on hot seat what was bart's
question [ __ ] what was his favorite kind
of paint color for our house
yeah it was like what's yeah it was like
do you like leather seats hey do you
like nachos or no
even that one's a little too spicy by
the way
hot seat
the best three best first three minutes
of any video ever
when it's really cold
and people can click away you're trying
to grab attention so smart so like i
said this guy was composing sentences at
a rate of just one character per minute
the man also asked to listen to the band
tool laos he requested a head massage
from his mother and ordered a curry all
through the thought is this in the uk i
like this dude i i know not where it is
beer and curry sounds like some uk's
head rub dude what's the first thing you
guys asked for while composing one
character a minute and you're paralyzed
kill me
yeah that's not bad not bad you got to
ask for it kill me
i thought about it
wait so this person can chew and eat
you guys
if he's asking for curry or else he's
sticking a straw and drinking it like a
gay dude
you're going to the curry restaurant
you're just like all right which one of
you [ __ ] got straws in here
what the [ __ ]
also terrible way to eat curry but
probably the worst way to eat curry
spice first is better than that it's too
thick for a strawberry
i wouldn't be mad that they're getting
mad they're [ __ ] drinking curry
through a straw you're like a boba
strawberry i'd be mad at
both i was all standing here with the
[ __ ] curry like
this [ __ ] tikka masala is off the
[ __ ] hook just use the cardboard tube
from like toilet paper
like in first kid where sinbad blows the
[ __ ] spitball hey that's good though
it took out secret service oh my god
secret service didn't train for that
they weren't ready for that the man who
is now 36 had two square electrode
arrays surgically implanted into his
brain to facilitate gay communication
march 2019 after being left in a
locked-in state as a result of uh
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis
did you guys really just let me slide
with the gay communication part i heard
it but i let it slide um only because
it's trying to back him up and stay in
the conversation theme
make sure he's not out there on a limb
i'm with hasagawa i would just be like
kill me bro why i don't want to be a i
will person
i just have a personality of like i
don't want to be a [ __ ] burden
well i don't want to be stuck in there i
can't do anything but like also i'm not
in that situation so when i get there
maybe i'm like wait no don't pull the
plug
you said you always wanted this
record and i'm like oh my god my kids
are going to [ __ ] me up that i'm in this
position i can't no i can't type fast
enough yeah it's like i'm just kidding j
k he's like we know you worked for that
company for a long time
i like the bravery of what ryan said
because he's like hey look you know if
i'm part of the disabled community just
pull the plug
i don't want to be a bird into society
no my birth i thought that everyone was
disabled to burden but my personality
applied to that i would feel too guilty
especially if this hospital bed could be
used for someone and should be alive and
i'm also predicting that i'm i'm in that
condition because of some [ __ ] i did
well you think als is something he did i
will find a [ __ ] way to cause it to
myself
honestly and you know what not
karmically speaking but maybe
it's because he didn't cry by 9 11 that
year he credited about final fantasy
[Music]
and we have so many guys guilt
we can't hold that guilt about it that
was on the ps2 the graphics were way
better than any videos of the plane
hitting the buildings yeah true too
guilty man can you imagine if i compared
it to this first thing i'd say i'm all
like look at these videos fake let me
get back to this final fantasy [ __ ] this
is real
in the title final cloud is real to me
how long has it been since i got my dick
touched what eight years oh that's to be
the first thing yeah someone touched my
dick
well you're paralyzed you might not feel
it so his friend really did hook him up
huh yeah i was like wait are you guys
together he goes no he goes i just had a
conversation i said like you know i
think i could get feeling in it like can
you hook me up and then she's like yeah
and i think they were kind of talking
badass man yeah gangster it's a sweet
move that's a homie move
though he said that it hurt can they
teach my [ __ ] wife how to do that
or um i think you just gotta pull the
hole my penis doesn't work
we're just talking about just dropping
random 500 sephora gift cards does that
not work no can we teach my [ __ ] wife
how to do this
i think i was pretty clear
so
people suffering from the progressive
neurodegenerative disease have an
average life expectancy after diagnosis
of two to five years though they can
live much longer the late physicist
stephen hawking lived another 55 years
after his diagnosis
but the cool thing or the most
interesting thing about this particular
situation is that this person was locked
in also he didn't have voluntary
muscular control so being able to do a
brain implant and have them communicate
it's actually kind of scientific and
health breakthrough
for for that that's tight yeah so you
could theoretically like implant this
like earlier and so that they could like
get accustomed to it and by the time
they get like locked in oh hey that's a
good okay that okay i take it back don't
pull the plug on me
run every [ __ ] test you want to try
to advance the cure on my use me as a
guinea pig
that's cool yeah
no i want to be a miracle dude i'll be
like they said he only had half a
percent chance of [ __ ] making it but
he [ __ ] made it and then i [ __ ]
lift to tell the tale you're still
typing kill me
and you die when you're 41
[Laughter]
from a car accident or something
this was the thing that was oh they put
a comb in him that was implanted into
the motor cortex looks like a [ __ ]
hair clipper inside of a condom dude it
looks like a nouveau ring my [ __ ] wife
would have inside of her
are body on this [ __ ] hey don't do it
one more time
i'm glad he brought up my favorite thing
the new ring dude
he actually leaned over whispered he's
like you gotta do it one more time
i like his modern danger field [ __ ]
perspective on your wife's hands
i get no respect
i get no respect
it took three months of unsuccessful
attempts before a configuration was
achieved that allowed the patient to use
brain signals to produce a binary
response to a speller program answering
yes or no when presented with letters oh
that's why it takes so [ __ ] long yeah
so probably in the minute that it takes
something to go through all
or something like that no this is like
when texting first came out we had to do
the [ __ ] goddamn tv
yeah t9 was like ah three times to get
to g
it's probably before that when you're
using like a rotary phone and you're
just like yeah exactly damn 9-1-1 back
in the days
died
it took nine times one
one oh [ __ ] i died no but the one was
close right it was like nine
and then you're like one
one one
back in the day wouldn't you just go
operator connect me to a local emergency
while you're getting attacked
someone's breaking into my house
after that it took another three weeks
to produce the first sentences and over
the next year the patient produced
dozens of sentences so like it's
actually quite he's talking too much
this guy won't shut up this guy
isn't dozens bad in the year holy [ __ ]
dozens
when i think about how much my [ __ ] wife
talks
and three for the win that was that was
four
i broke the rule carmody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you